the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to day two
of the 2022 fall chess classic yesterday
we were able to see quite a lot of very
exciting action and we're hoping that
something that continues into today my
name is Jonathan trance and I'm joined
here by Grand Master Eugenie Miro yeah
we're going to go with Miro I think
that's a little bit easier for her at
least for me to say I don't know how you
guys are feeling at home but it's great
to have you with us and I'm glad we can
all very much and for those who were
wondering it's not that Jonathan much
taller it's my chair is a little bit low
adjusted uh was this out of the way
let's talk about this second round of
the standings after round one let's just
get right to it let's see who is playing
let's check out these standings for the
a group and yesterday we did see a
couple of decisive results in the a
group we had visits who actually had a
bad position at one point came back and
found a way to get this pass deep on all
the way down the board we also saw nijed
ebsav uh he played a very interesting
game where he won relatively quickly in
about 21 moves or so we have about the
rest of the field we've got
one when Nicholas theodoro Hall on a
half point and Aram and Surya still
looking to get some points in this
tournament and with that let's go ahead
Miro and take a look at the B group uh
well big group the station is quite the
opposite so we have two leaders in the a
group and we have only two people on 50
in the big group so a lot of results and
well my apologies to Christian sharilla
we left him and I kind of came up with
the idea that he has the winning
position perhaps it was such but he
eventually lost so four winners four
players tied for the first and four at
the bottom right sadwani cutridge
landemon uh Lindeman by the way won this
Everlasting end game right 70 plus moves
and yeah anti-grand harukinyan as well
and with that we'll go ahead and see the
format of this tournament uh this is a
two player there's two Fields there's
two ten player round Robins there's 90
minutes for the first 40 moves you get
an additional 30 minutes at move 40 and
after all throughout the game you get a
30 second increment so a relatively uh
well-known formats now let's go ahead
and check out our schedule for this
event Mira yeah schedule is pretty
straightforward right yesterday's round
one already
removed from the graphics each round is
played at 1 pm we have no three days and
the last round will start a couple of
hours earlier why is that because
playoff if necessary will be played on
the same day at 5 pm
wonderful land just so people do uh do
know we are checking in with you guys
here and maybe you can get a little bit
more interactive on this show I'm
sitting here I'm watching the chat I'm
looking at twitch I'm looking at YouTube
I want to give a big shout out to my
Queen gets around on Twitch I see
Patrick Daly on YouTube we are watching
all of the chats and if you do want to
get a hold of us on uh social media
please use the hashtag fall chess
classic watch all of the games live on
us chess Champs and be very active in
the chats because uh everything that you
do do whether you're watching on YouTube
or whether you're watching on Twitch all
of the money that we do make actually
goes to a fantastic cause and this will
be the part of the show where it would
be really awesome to get some hype
started maybe get some sort of hype
train on Twitch all of the bits and
subscriptions is going to an excellent
place every 75 dollars that we raise
actually goes to getting one kid an
entire semester of programming uh we
have grand Masters that go out to
different schools and they're able to
give classes every single week to kids
so every 75 dollars is an entire program
which is typically 10 weeks for kids so
thank you everybody joining us today now
uh with all of that in mind let's go
ahead and get into the action right away
and let's go ahead and check out the
pairings for the a group all right so we
have Gregorio parin with one win ninjata
vasov with you young is in the lead but
yeah very very tough opposition Vivid
also has the white pieces that means
both leads won with black yesterday with
it against Nicholas theodoro Ilya niznik
against Surya Ganguly and the man
himself Hans Neiman with the white
person I can see we see Jack we know
what they're looking for I can see you
guys everybody wants to know what's
going on in the game between Hans Neiman
and Aram hakobian so let's not
disappoint the people let's jump right
into it and see exactly what we got
going on all right that's that's the
current position of the Hans just move
the Queen the queen got attacked with
stroke on D2 so he played Queen C3
that's moved 27 we are talking about uh
while the opening not wasn't that
impressive particularly what is it
possible to look at it I mean yes
started very quiet so as Italian would
say the the game was very quiet Joker
was quite quite piano yeah uh Bishop to
C4 Bishop C5 D3 castles and that once
again if we are digging a bit too deeper
uh it actually has some point to it
castling before going C3 because if
black castles and then of the C3 plans
to go D5 then instead of C3 you can you
can actually play Bishop G5 or some
other stuff uh right so well some
subtleties with the moves over but it is
getting transposed into main lines of
the D6 C3 A6 that that's that's kind of
an old-fashioned old-fashioned thingy
before Bishop E6 Bishop takes Rook takes
and then
well Bishop G5 is kind of a
newish move at least to me because
Knight bd2 I still remember was played
by oh okay maybe you've heard of those
guys crumbling around yeah
so Bishop to G5 H6 and why just trades
on F6 he has 92. you know what sometimes
I have a feeling that when you look at
those big players like 2700 2700 plus
it's very tempting to try to look for an
opening idea I mean so the guy yeah
since he played this perhaps he might
know something yeah but yeah but it's
not often the case I mean it might have
been okay let's let's play Bishop G5 was
this opening in particular the Joko
pianizimo like I mean it just seems like
there's so many teeny tiny little
nuances is this something I mean
obviously you have some sort of ideas
are people actually specifically with
this opening memorizing tons of theory
or is it mainly just the ideas that you
think they're coming out I don't think
so I mean maybe like you will a handful
of people like Magnus I imagine yeah
right I mean sure because they tend to
prove but let's say even Grandmasters
who have very strong Grand Masters who
are playing in our a group I believe
it's more about uh okay here is this
plan and then if he goes to say A6 I'm
suppose
moreover you know you're sailing without
navigation without anything but there
are lighthouses so you see this one okay
I I pivot here so perhaps that that's
how it goes and some round display feels
like position is completely equal
to be perfectly honest and if anyone
it's actually black who's first to grab
the D file White House has a little bit
more space so
should be should be around equal yeah
and then hunt starts I guess somewhere
around here starts to
gonna try to play for more than a draw
let's put it this way I mean it's not
that many options left
uh Queen to B2
Queen E6 counter attacking H3
King to G2 F7 F6
and this is something
I kind of I've specifically didn't like
the structure that he yeah no no no I
mean hans's last move like Knight H4 so
structured yeah I mean he already
created some holes here right uh
Jacobian then B5 is on your agenda but
I'm as let's say as a classical as an
old guy as a classical player I'm not
very happy with black controlling the D
file so I would try to challenge black
on the D5 maybe go in Queen C2 the queen
was there a couple of minutes ago anyway
right and Knight H4 not only doesn't
fight for the D file but actually
invites Rook D2 so I'd be a little bit
scared
uh Quincy tree Hans not scared and yeah
so here we are 27 moves 18 minutes left
for huckabian and there's still maybe
some stuff that I guess white could
potentially consider I mean the knights
coming to F5 at some point maybe you
have a B4 break maybe at some point you
could do something on the king side yeah
well I mean if you manage to get to a
five you you're pretty much
automatically land on D6 so I wonder if
black just plays G6 which stops Knight
F5 but at the same time kind of makes
his uh King side even looser and I
wonder if this is maybe his idea is he
trying to provoke like G6 and he can
always bring his yeah maybe yeah
who cares your Rook came in I kick you
back
but uh okay well have you seen what
happens in this one I think they're
still actually it started a little bit
boring but I think maybe there's still a
little bit of action something worth
coming back to for sure but let's also
talk about the other section because
there's also a b section here so let's
go ahead and check out the pairings for
this round uh with the the top billing
here we got tigrant heartunyan going up
against Christopher you today akshat
Chandra is going up against Alex
versus Dennis kandrick Brandon Jacobson
versus ronik sadhwani in our star
matchup at least the one that we're
going to be checking out first things
first is our own uh commentator
Christian Carrillo going up against
cantar and we were talking yesterday
about how we thought when we left the
show that Christian actually had a
fantastic position but that was not the
case he actually uh somehow managed to
lose so both of these players are
unfortunately sitting on zero points but
let's jump into it because I think they
had something interesting going on early
Mira yeah a very interesting position
and once again in noticeable uh
difference between a group and the big
group and I wouldn't call that say a
group knows their Theory better but
they're much faster developing like it's
interesting to see the middle middle
game while now that I'm checking the
round like all rounding in the big group
after what is that like three hours of
play or two and a half hours of play and
early opening stage most of the most of
the games
you'd like to spend a lot of time really
like to kind of
start playing the most competitive yes
there's like a reason do good players
just not need as much time to come up
with good moves or is it a clear evening
what's the reason I think I think
strangely it's more of a
um
in this higher levels they have this I
respect you you respect me attitude
right so I mean if there is an open file
let's trade all the rooms there you know
and and these guys I mean how crazy it
is move 16 uh Christian yeah they're
both down to like 20 less than 20
minutes
yeah interesting so we definitely have
our eye on this one but I've also just
heard that uh ronak sadwani who's
actually one of our tournament leaders
has potentially just won another game
today so I'm going to check in with this
one as well in the B-side let me see
yeah that that's the first uh result for
today one with the black pieces and I
haven't seen much of these games so yeah
we can start from let's just yeah I'm
sure most people just quickly go through
right so yeah the good old names still
serves pretty well I guess right not in
this occasion I guess it did for black
from Black's point of view it certainly
did work out today seven see how they
got two b six Bishop B2 yeah once again
I mean if to point out something this
queen C7 is considered to be kind of
clever clever moves on it so Bishop E2
goes down goes down
ah right and why is that because Bishop
D3 and that's the stuff you'd like to
play normally you want to put the
bishopone D3 and B2 to go for E4 but
this time it's C takes he takes a check
and in order to guard The Rook you have
to block with the bishop but then the
other Bishop is lost okay so that that's
kind of a time it's a good little point
though tiny but important Point yeah
all right and with division E2 it's much
harder to play E4 of course so he goes
for C4 and once again I believe uh like
this possibly
had been known to both plays in fact I
mean this does look like some
theoretical position to me Knight to G6
Knight to D3 well logical perhaps Bishop
F1 H5 Alpha zero style I mean push the
pawn you have the pawn push the pawn
right
Queen to E2 H4 F3 while logical kind of
stopping the oh I don't know building a
fence right against this bishop Knight
to H7 dc5 H3 ah yeah and now I cannot
recall it yeah this is the position I've
seen when I was checking the live games
H3 a very interesting intermezza
it's a inviting perhaps uh White to take
on B6 where he's gonna take on G2 and
then F3 Pawn is kind of shaky uh black
all of a sudden gets a lot of everything
you need to somehow get into the game
and this would be very good yeah very
very attractive squares but uh White
display G3 which looks solid and even
kind of more logical talk about the
h-man it tap it happens to be
persistence it has a perhaps a decisive
mistake right to G5 F3 and F5 is
particularly strong so F5 and he breaks
through on the light squares and white
reacted with e takes yeah F5
uh well last Knight F3
but you know what happened yeah I mean
Black's about to do something brilliant
stage four and
um
honestly
that's such a clever idea so when you
take the G file it's a check and if
first of all you can't really go to F2
because now it's Queen H4 very nice
right so before that the plan was I mean
basically when white captures on F5 he
already yeah it gives up the exchange by
let's say allowing Knight F3 and so on
right so after Knight H4 it's check you
can't go to F2 and after King H1 I
reckon I mean first of all you can just
take the route but yeah also this must
work I mean check over here check over
here and then then you might actually
bring the queen in as well attracting
and this you know this diagonal it's
just yeah it's absolutely beautiful yeah
monstrously big win there so huge news
for ronic who now sits on two points two
out of two that's that's as good as it
gets absolutely wonderful so are there
any other games we can actually take a
little trip around the horn and see uh
potentially maybe we want to head back
to the a group and see what another yes
yeah let's update let's update to the
Chats on the station Eda group because
here no results whatsoever
hunts this game in fact black did not
play G6 but Hans decided to return the
Knight to F3 anyway perhaps because
Knight F5 is met with something like
Knight G5 you can go to D6 H3 is hanging
and also black has a threat of capturing
on e4 and then removing a defender of
the night it's very nice yeah so very
nice idea by black so instead he went
Knight F3 tries to push this Rook away
and perhaps he'll be back to what I was
originally mentioning and start trading
the Rooks yeah I mean yeah it was all
seriousness though white shouldn't be at
any risk of losing I mean if thing goes
badly you just go Queen B3 trade the
Queens go B5 trade the pawns and that
should be enough for a draw all right
well we'll come back to this one but
what else is going on in the ASL well
I'll just go one by one operating
against one win
uh what's here uh White is a pawn down
but I suppose that's the point he
sacrificed because the Rook on H5 looks
almost trapped while it's last move
being H2 H4 so
G4 is an actual threat
and then if
black girls C4 kind of clearing the
fifth rank I assume F5 is what white
wants to play look at that so F5 if you
capture in Bishop F3 and that that's a
nice that's an action that's a nice
connection strap there
that's a nice position so is there
actually wait how do we get this Rook
out of here we gotta yeah I mean there's
we have five but then you're you're not
you're trapped in there as well yeah
could it be that we don't is there I
mean probably we do not resign just yet
because we can I mean if there is
nothing better we could try Rook to D5
just yeah I I understand it's not very
attractive but Bishop takes Knight takes
I suspect why it has to be better with
precise play something along the lines
of Rook D2 captures and Rook C1 starts
attacking those Pawns
uh but yeah but the game's on the game
is on and very entertaining I believe
Right Moving on ninjata bus against you
young years and one of the tournament
leaders against one of the top seeds
um well currently and this was our
Sicilian game yeah that was there was a
well quite a quite the sharp Sicilian at
some point so now it's I'm the kind of
guy that needs to see it all from this
yeah yeah sure let's go in order to
commit all these games
nowadays everyone knows what's neither
variation is and that's exactly what
happened all right good old Niner uh
Bishop between two uh not the most
popular but once again if you'd ask
karpov and kaspar of these guys yeah
let's play like couple of a couple of
um world championship matches right
Bishop D7 to E3 castles and yeah
would be Castle short yes like for
another 20 moves and only then the og4
right but this is the point yeah just
just go G4 after Queen A5 who cares
about them temp ago Bishop D3 but yeah
your ID is quite straightforward go G5
move the queen castle long just check
made him yeah Knight to C6 White
doesn't want to
doesn't want to trade so goes here goes
here Rook to G1 first
and after B5 goes Rook to G3 so a little
bit artificial
like instead of running the pawn up the
board and opening the file he's trying
to kind of just uh I don't know you're
on the H5 wrongly from this phone right
yeah and then just yeah put the Rook on
a tree Queen H5 and he apparently
getting stopped like this rookie eight
and wow Knight to B4 that's fine but how
is he not expected Knight f8 of course
yeah yeah castles now it turns out he's
in time to take on D3 as well go before
the White's basically whenever white
plays Rook H3 there is always a knight
of Fate yeah Bishop to B7
well actually well actually this does
look like very pleasant position for
black already since while white kind of
failed to achieve anything substantial
white backs up goes Queen two takes
takes and Knight to see Bishop d8 first
oh well that's spectacular Bishop d8
from D2 Knight to C5
that's a little tricky because Rook Rook
D6 the pawn on e4 is hanging okay so it
has to take one takes and Rook to G1 all
right
so we didn't give Checkmate we've got
into this end game all right I'm
thinking black is probably looking for
the way to
allowed to play for an advantage it's
it's too early to say if black has
something substantial but pair of
Bishops and somehow you know
the general experience like whenever you
get whenever you survive till the end
games in the Sicilian right said yeah
somehow it always feels like these White
ponds get over extended over on the the
king side somehow they all become
Targets later if you don't give
Checkmate mm-hmm
they already have some endgame opposite
colored Bishops where but it is upon up
okay just quickly we'll run through this
one Knight to C3 C5 which is uh okay
defense yeah and then no such [ __ ] is
storage but just a symmetrical
symmetrical line a six yeah that's one
of those like really amazing positions
because no not even A6 but this one
because
white basically says that I'm ready to
play with an isolated Pawn because if
you take CD4 I take eg4 but if you don't
take then you'll be the one yeah it's
isolated yeah it's definitely and you're
with black you're kind of confused but
but is it good or bad to have an
isolator because I can make you play
with the isolated phone I I can have an
isolate Pawn myself okay
A6 so now he is prepared I mean first of
all he kind of waits for this bishop to
move
and then black takes and instead of
taking recapturing on C4 in one go
you're gonna spend it that's also
waiting he's not moving his Bishop on f8
yet because he's okay he's waiting for
the same exact they're playing the same
Mouse game on both sides here yeah so
cd5 ed5 G3 and and to be perfectly
honest G3 I'm not sure if I've ever seen
in this position but it doesn't
necessarily mean it's a bad move uh G3
and then one more uh
plus behind this having a7a6 blade that
you can actually play C4 and if needed
back it up with B7 default okay yeah so
Bishop G2 Bishop B4 will what have been
almost any pawn structure but we're
gonna see this one here yeah well but
but what's interesting black actually
plays in a very ambitious fashion
and I have to say yeah
trade it here B3 A5
okay and then now I kind of don't like
it all that much okay so he had a clever
way to not have to take on C4 okay at
least had some clever idea behind it
yeah
F3 but how did he ended up losing a pawn
uh oh yeah I remember when checking this
one actually felt
uh for those uh I don't know kind of
older and more experienced Chatters uh I
felt Petros and wipes you know this game
when he played rookie 7 to E6 under
attack of the bishop which is published
like literally everywhere the the escape
the closest exchange sacrifice keep it
frozen was it yeah so the bishop is here
and then he plays like rookie six it's
some similarities but anyway Queen A4
happens to be a double attack on the
bishop A5 pawn bishop D3 E5 once again
with a Tempo Knight goes to D5 white
captures Knight C3 Quincy tree
everything's guarded black couldn't find
anything better but the trade
uh okay and it was his decision to take
the Knight yeah interesting so he values
this a pawn more than uh than a two
Bishops Advantage yeah fair enough
all right
rookie one and this is where we stand
now interesting and for those that
actually don't know Nicholas theodoro
joined this tournament a little bit late
we had a player withdraw at kind of the
last second here and so he's only had
maybe one or two days to potentially
prepare for different opponents and as
somebody that I guess has played not
only in this tournament but in similar
high-level events how much does that
like affect like your preparation or how
much you're able to do or do you think
that like you pick different openings
because you have a significantly smaller
amount of time to prepare that's
actually any effect that's actually a
big question now depends on how how well
or how bad you are prepared overall
right because if you trust your openings
all the time then okay perhaps the most
tempting Choice okay I've kind of snuck
in in the last moment let's see where we
stand right
well for me it'd be a disaster because I
was always kind of trying to Target
uh my opponent specifically and that's
an excuse for not knowing everything
well right okay I'll do a specific
preparation guys don't worry I don't
have to care about my opening repairs
right yeah I'll prepare again two very
different philosophies the benefit of
course being that yeah you can always
prepare as well for you surprise your
opponents yeah but but then you need
time for this right you you learn okay
I'm playing the round Robert I have a
month and then let's think okay I'm
playing white with this guy all black so
I kind of prepare for both case
scenarios uh he didn't have this luxury
so indeed he probably should have a
second
uh maybe he wants it to be a little bit
harder for people to prep for him but
we'll see how it goes uh for Nicholas
Theodora who all right and there's an
interesting game here there is one more
game that we didn't look let's go ahead
and check this at all and that's Ilya
nejnik who oh wow who has I want to say
sacrifice the queen but we do not know
for sure wow yeah yeah what's Happening
Here
holy cow believe it or not but that's
actually a joke or another joke another
joke as we've seen this can become
literally anything yeah
a6a4 Bishop to A7 well yeah though on
ilia's hand I do have a little bit of
insight for those who don't know Ilya is
a uh he does do a lot of work here for
us he does a lot of the streams that you
might be watching here on Twitch shout
out to everybody hey REM shocked how's
it going uh he I know for a fact is one
that is said kind of publicly that he
doesn't think that he's as well prepared
in his openings as somebody else and
this actually may be the kind of opening
that suits his style because you it's
kind of one of those ones where maybe
you don't need to be as heavily dense
into the theory if you just kind of know
the ideas you can kind of come up with
the Right Moves and plans and I think
that definitely is ilya's style so yeah
wondering you know I'm honestly
wondering about his opponent's move the
the bishop B6 move because I think we
even talked about this yesterday and I
was kind of been told on many occasions
that
this is not what you're supposed to be
doing like Bishop E6 is not such a great
idea when white has a 4 and B4 plate
like where white has the space
uh all right sir captured here Knight G3
and once again the thoughts about this
position they usually evolve with um you
know the level of Chess understanding
because I remember being like a kid and
God give me this semi-open f file the
easiest way to attack it probably create
an ice cream
because yeah you know I mean you just
move the Knight you double you sacrifice
on the screen you win you then somehow
when the place is white getting a little
bit more advanced you understand that
yeah double Pawn is the double Pawn
nobody's interested to get checkmated
they tend to defend and so on yes anyway
so our game developed uh This Way Queen
to beat three perhaps targets the B7
Pawn I don't know okay it's been a lot
of moves
that's perhaps the next stop when the
structure got polarized even further
right so white has four versus two on
the king side or the right side of the
board black has the same on the left
side uh rookie eight Rook to A3 nice
maneuver
and ah okay that's deep because I mean
after Rook a tree you want to say and
Rook G3 comes logically but but not
really because Knight D4 Knight d4h4
Pawn was hanging so that's why he went
from B1 to capture one default with the
Rook if needed Knight to D4 Knight back
to F3 so that that part is a little bit
confusing I wanted to pretend it was a
very logical game though but yes G6
Knight xh6 Queen G7
okay so first questions first questions
is night getting trapped apparently not
right
because white just captures on D5 so
that's what he wanted to do captions on
D5 if Knight takes he perhaps just goes
back
it says I'm gonna pull up right very
nice so the Knight on the street is not
hanging it's guarded by The Rook
so instead black has tactical shot of
his own so Knight to E2 Queen to E2
Knight to D4 okay attacks the queen a
lot of things yeah everything and the H6
guy is still hanging but white comes up
with Queen takes Rogue now what's
interesting he could have captured yes
the Knight on F3 with a check Rook takes
Rook takes but then I reckon it's check
King G8 D6
and it's impossible to stop the
performance we've seen it before they
get rolling pretty fast impossible to
stop the pawn and even if you trade the
Queens as far as I can see it's it's a
winning Rook end game as the result so
therefore black captures only 8
immediately white has to spend the time
to take on D4 and queen and now he
doesn't even take on H6 what's that is
it is there an issue with teaching on H6
ah there wasn't there wasn't it's just
that look at face creates
[Laughter]
this is perhaps the biggest thing I'm
taking away from all these games it's
just whenever there's some simple
recapture yeah always love the movement
always complicate with some sort of
weird yeah but I still don't quite get
it uh capturing 26 well perhaps if you
spend some time calculating you probably
figure out that D6 wins or something
like that because black captures on B2
but that's it's just it's just bad weird
yeah what do you how do you even
continue from there I mean Knight
Returns and like two moves needed and
then it you know the fog the fog you can
push it disappear here for white this
actually is yeah you just win
just winning for white for Ilia
holy cows this is one to definitely keep
on watch we just saw the move Queen to
E2
Rook one to D2 I suggest I mean you
you're not forced to
you can yeah I mean just just need to
care
for this not uh maybe you are forced in
fact
but yeah but does it change anything I
mean Rook D2
that's the problem and since the Knight
on H6 survived you can never really
trade the queen for for pieces right
yeah some sort of like attack here or
somehow he was winning the other night
back or something I don't know exactly
what was going on but maybe this is good
for white honestly it looks lost looks
lost for Ganguly he's down to one last
minute on move 34 so another option
translate it could be just a terrible
time trouble and then he was not
satisfied say with the capture on H6 and
usually how it goes you calculate one
with more or less precisely if you're
not satisfied you might go for the other
one which possibly is even worse it's
actually good to see I know Ilya was
just playing in a tournament two right
before this that thousand Grandmaster
event
um and I know that yeah I'm speaking to
him on the phone because I asked him how
his tournament went and I don't he
didn't tell me exactly but I could tell
from what he was saying that maybe he
didn't have his best event of all time
so uh he was looking to hopefully bounce
back uh and have a good tournament here
this time so good to see Ilya in you
know such a fun interesting position
still and be cool to see how this game
continues all right so just quickly
going to check once again what happens
in Neiman's game against Jacobian
not a lot of development here so after
Knight F3 Rook went back to D7 H4 okay
preventing the knight from G5 rookie two
queen G4 now black has gotta has some
go away yep
rookie tree a lot of maneuvering this is
going to be a battle we're going to see
a lot of little teeny tiny Maneuvers
both signs waiting to see if the other
side will crack uh which I guess is a
good sign they're still fighting there's
easy easy ways to maybe make a draw
earlier on but it's good to see that
both of these guys are still battling it
out
um all right and now that I'm looking at
the gems and well once again perhaps
white is sorry black is tempted to go
from Knight G6 maybe not definitely yes
but yeah but then I'm thinking if we try
to trade the Rooks I mean I'm not sure
if it works but if it does then usually
in the end game these guys will be off
right I mean it could be a little bit a
little bit kind of misplaced and so on
and then it will be about white getting
to D7 say taking B7 pawns it can be
anything despite some kind of quiet
looking it can be any anybody's game uh
let's check the B group yeah let's go
ahead and jump on back over to the B
group see what's going on maybe we have
some uh interesting games uh that's the
one that we've checked already that's
the only game that finished so far so
far one decisive win for ronak who is
now sitting at two points overall yeah
this was our star game of the day coming
into the round yeah the game between
Christian carrilla and uh Greg Gurley
and yeah we kind of mentioned that
potentially black would have these two
Bishops and are they doing anything or
are they just hanging out that's so
strange I mean the the whole position
how do you how do you play this one so
well just quickly run through it's it's
not so so many anyway it's move 19. so
there was this coach which is kind of
Forgotten when we are talking about the
Magnus and France nobody nobody's
playing discouraged this is at least our
second Scotch now we're seeing yeah but
interestingly enough when it happens
it turns out nobody remembers what to do
against this coach so white results in
the scotch are not bad at all everything
that's old is now new again yeah Queenie
two that's still the theory Knight to D5
yeah and this this move H4 this is some
new movement yeah it's relatively recent
move on I think it was played on High
level as well but
this is what Apple has played or
something yeah so that's what was played
in our game a5c4 Knight to B6 once again
me personally I've never really figured
out I mean when do you play Bishop A6
when yes spawn right when a girl knight
B6 some some guys go as far as just move
the Knight of B6 like before
yeah anyway so let's just follow let's
believe the players G3 A4 why not
going to E6
92 Bishop B4 consoles
Knight E4 and perhaps it turns out the
point yeah I mean that that's that's the
question which one because C4 was also
heavy
uh he captures E5 going to C2 C5
actually I don't like C5 now that I'm
thinking because
I don't know if it's possible but it's
supposed to be like this right so that
the Knight on B6 is cut off but
apparently d75 is a threat
okay yeah so yeah interesting Pawn
sacrifice I'm not sure yeah no but
perhaps he hasn't ever seen the exact
reason yet but maybe is there like a
concrete reason or is this some sort of
long term we'll get to attack your queen
again later why did he sacrifice that
Five Guys he lost the pawn yeah that's
it
um perhaps
oh well if you think of it and how do we
untie the the whole the whole setup
because we have to make a move yeah
maybe a four is the move yeah once again
I don't know maybe F4 was the move
anyway Christian found it to be
attractive C5 A3
Rook to D1 okay Bishop A6 Bishop to H3
huh well funny funny tricks and Knight
to G5 then threading mate and the queen
and the queen yeah
okay so there's a bishop A3 and queen
ready to H5
so now the question is what do we do
Bishop G5 Maybe
Knight G5
yeah what I'm also Almost sure that we
do not take on D7 being undeveloped you
know and accept the challenge yeah I'd
like to see yeah
it's actually quite unpleasant yeah
so right but once again the position is
so original so off the charts that it's
no surprise that both of them spent like
enormous amount of time Christian is
down to four minutes only his opponent
is down to 10 and it's still still 20
moves 20 moves it is very complicated it
does seem like there could be a tactic
looking around any corner here yeah
um I guess it is kind of important to
note that that those light score Bishops
probably do needs to stay pretty close
for that King because it's both sides
here I could just imagine getting into a
little bit of trouble if you're not
careful so this one will be a cool one
to keep our eyes on
absolutely so and if we can actually
head back to the Ilia Niche neck game I
think we may have a major update
so Elias game uh well the major update
being the game is over that's a big
update yeah so right but but we we leave
this one we actually were correct yeah
this was the queen Sacrifice game well
it turns out you know it turns out it
was a good sacrifice it was it turns out
that 92 was a terrible mistake and
that's after that there was not much to
do for I mean so why has done everything
correctly basically wonderful that was
that was winning anyway so just to see
what was kind of the last moves played
Rook uh Queen to B2 Rook B3 Queen E2
that's what we've seen
D6 plain and simple if Rook takes F3
Rook D2 now very nice wow and then D7
next yes so you can't really do much G3
okay and that's not the same three years
yes right yesterday Rook G3 let the
Perpetual check well actually wasn't it
in Ninja's game
he's aware but possibly quite possibly
yeah but today white does have the way
to avoid the Perpetual of the queen F2
which is the only not the only check we
have two King H3 or queen queen H4 maybe
it seems natural because you're also on
the promotion square but uh yeah but how
do we how do we run away ah we go here
that's the only check we go here down
Knight is very helpful and then the last
check is this and now I'm sure it's the
last check because not G4 wonderful and
uh great to see Ilya getting on the
board now yesterday people were telling
us that you know these interviews
they're they looked a little bit more
like a VHS tape you know so you know
what just for just for these guys I mean
that was intentional obviously we said
you didn't like it don't let them don't
let them out do the commentators but you
know what today we have done a major
update so I cannot wait to see This
brilliant interview that we have going
on today with Ilya nijnick let's tune it
in
all right I am here with Grand Master
Ilia nishnik off his win against Grand
Master bully uh how did it happen
Grandmaster take me through the game and
just you know tell me all about it well
um uh just to begin with I think my
opening Choice must have strong strong
um sorry off a little bit because I I
started with the move E4 which I don't
usually play so we we had a relatively
uh standard like Italian you know
structure it's our Italian game
um where I believe Surya had a pretty
decent position but then you know he
made a couple of what I believe were
questionable decisions especially his
choice of playing E5
on move 18. so the move E5
um
allowed me to release pressure in the
center and that's kind of what I was
looking for just kind of open things up
in the center Because unless he unless
you put people sd5 himself I I wasn't
quite sure how I'm going to be making
progress in that position I had a couple
of couple of ideas but if I definitely
kind of kind of put me on a on a right
State of Mind where I I knew exactly
that I'm supposed to be playing in the
center so after he played E5 yeah the
game suddenly became really really
Dynamic where
well I would say unsurprisingly so
because after he plays E5
um he will have to deal with quite a few
weaknesses in his position so he decided
to kind of um make the game a little bit
more exciting
um and um and but it's a move I Believe
by the move
um by the move 26 uh the spot where I
played now to F3 I was already very uh
very confident that I'm my position is
close to winning
um however
and a couple of moves after I point out
F3 so we're talking
um move
29 right so at night of three D5
G3 G6 96.27 here I thought that after
after I captured the pawn on D5
everything just magically works out and
I wasn't really aware of the fact that
that uh Surya had not what he did in the
game because in the game serial plot 92
which heavily was a critical mistake
that forces the game but instead of 92
Syria should have started with Knight to
D4
um that move
um has the same idea behind it but
um because uh the Knight Still Remains
on the four right so the Knight remains
untouched it it keeps the option of
going to H3 so that's the point when
Black Goes Knight D4 now if I take was a
knight black has Knight H3 check and
because my my F2 Pawn is exposed
um essentially that would have been a
better version of what happened in the
game and I believe that position was
quite it's quite quite likely that Surya
would have survived sir but in the game
what happened was I I gave up my queen
for um for rook in the night while also
maintaining a couple of couple of Pawns
um I also had a couple of pawns for the
material and also very importantly I
passed Pawn on the D file which which
obviously played a critical role in in
me winning the game so um
with with Knight D4 I believe sorry I
would have at least gotten one of his
missing pawns back and would have also
exposed my king which I think should
have given him enough counter Play to
save the game so
um that's how I feel about this and I
hope that's
oh yeah good enough over there oh lovely
lovely way to play the second round
alienation thank you so much for coming
on thank you for having me good luck so
there you have it that was ilianize Nick
maybe maybe his opponent had a knight D4
resource in there somewhere very
interesting to get his take on that very
imbalanced game and thank you once again
to Jacob Sanders who will be providing
all of these interviews throughout this
event so absolutely with improved camera
quality yes then chat was very impressed
everybody loved it so when things only
get better as the days go you know what
we absolutely have to look at hans's
game because yes things are heating up
well not on the clock though because
Hans just reached move 40 right they do
receive 30 minutes
uh all right it's a queen to E2 was the
move after which Knight f44 we do see a
sacrifice but perhaps not uh to try to
win but rather to force a draw no
say it's not true uh that's the position
well so they've had this twice now is
this if the queen goes to G4 how many
yeah
that'd be three perhaps and he's called
an Arbiter and he says I'm about to make
my threefold repetition
well can he actually try to do that not
not really I was thinking some Rook D2
but then Queen takes that's the problem
yeah like I'm not even sure if this is a
Checkmate apparently not right that the
King's Running but oh sorry yeah runs to
G4 and so on but even if it's a
Checkmate then white always has plan B
to take with the queen and it will be
yeah
we can see it work out here so is what
we are expecting yeah it's very likely
we'll just finish in a Perpetual check
uh which means yeah Hans will be helpful
draw yeah you have another time yep yep
so if this ends in a draw too he also
there's a big pairing for Hans coming up
tomorrow tomorrow's going to be a huge
matchup we'll have you Yang Yi with the
white pieces going up against Hans
Neiman so that's a must-watch game
tomorrow
uh right meanwhile we just got another
result of parin makes a draw against one
win
uh what was that what was the position
again ah dude they didn't get trapped it
didn't no okay or maybe yeah uh H4 is
what we've seen last all right and it
turns out not Rook D5 but Knight D5 is
possible and how is that I mean I got a
G4 I thought
uh a check over here
King goes to F3 right because if King
goes to the first rank
then we don't know what happens right
this looks like a duplicated study where
no matter where you go there's just one
particular line there is something yeah
like King E1 I was originally thinking
but then Knight takes F4 and then the
Rook gets the square and if you take
then it's a check followed by rookie
four and black is getting this position
exchange for the pawns but many more
complicated many more points than in our
line right uh so stuff is so hard to
figure out when there's so many moves to
calculate here in fact a computer says
that it it was all equal so means both
players played nearly perfect F5 I think
this is the kind of game where when
they're both talking about it in the
post-mortem they say like I don't know
what was going on I wasn't sure yeah
yeah the computer just says yeah it was
fine obviously you guys play great
it's a church
yeah and Neiman's game is officially
obviously okay so we saw a revolution
there so a couple draws now the two
games are in progress in the a group
once again reminder those are abbasov
and you Yankee where it's only move 32
that means yeah a bus up specifically is
down to four minutes only
still has 12. looks like he's got two
Bishops and an extra Pawn all right so
something like that we've seen yes
for the early Checkmate but uh Queens
got traded off Bishop C6 and B3 okay
don't take spawn takes and if you
capture believe it will be about some
discovered attacks I don't know like
Bishop A5 may be Then followed by Bishop
E4 and all the pieces disappear from the
C file so white decided to go E5 but
then B take C2 and it's not that easy to
and perhaps you can't really take it for
now it's a 94 first Rook d896
you can
quite possibly you can take this guy
now the room if if the Rook takes
perhaps Bishop e no I mean I'm not sure
oh Bishop A4 maybe but I mean the key
key point is that the C2 Pawn survives
and this is something you don't want to
see right so you probably take with the
pawn where the Rook controls both the E4
and A4 squares
uh black girls Bishop D5 and while white
is trying to win the C2 Pawn black at
the very least captures D6 and will have
you know this never-ending end game with
Rooks opposite colored Bishops and one
side being a pawn up yeah these are
usually very very long games
and yeah to confirm on that we already
have one which is videoed against the
odoro these guys are somewhat closer to
the time control but still yeah the
game's on obviously and
I'm not sure how to feel about this
because yeah it is an extra Pawn for
white but black done quite well by
starting to trade the pawns trade the
Rooks and so on because like you know
remote in a distant future we might
start talking about this King running to
A8 you know black trading the bishop for
the last Pawn remaining and speculating
on on this fact that yeah the a pawn and
the bishop of a wrong color did not win
yeah so very likely we might see quite a
lot of draws in today's event uh things
are slowing down we had a lot of action
yesterday things may be slowing down in
round two okay but how about the B group
the big group perhaps is not planning to
slow down yes this one's still very
interesting yeah we've seen a movers
wait a second I mean I'm confused I'm
confused what's the yeah I'll just have
to yeah okay okay we do have some moves
23
white zone two minutes Plex on 3 but
he's to move so that's a disadvantage
usually when you're in time trouble
because you are the one spending time
right so the Rook D1 and the queen was
forced to H5 Rook to D4 yeah logical of
course I mean who needs development
anyway
uh
F5 Knight to C3 Bishop takes a black is
so happy to take with this A5 Bishop
because he was doing absolutely nothing
here
so Bishop takes Pawn takes Rook E8 and
white is happy as well finally
developing his Bishop from C1
okay I think well the dust kind of
settles down a little bit uh White
probably wins the A4 Pawn back at some
point but also black and if anything
just trade on F4 and try to try to play
solids perhaps it's it's sort of you
know white
probably slightly better that would be
my assessment let me cheat and and check
what computer has to say all right
experts experts in the studio broadcast
minus 1.6 so black is up one and a half
pounds uh mirror says quite slightly
better yeah
huh
so I guess yeah we can try to unpack
this one I guess and try to understand
exactly why oh well maybe because of
this myth Rook to E4 because I was yeah
I mean me as a you know chess pensioner
I was looking for the way to trade
pieces
peacefully you're trying to play in the
a section this is the B section where
they try to win oh yeah yeah sorry
for confusion yes a rookie four and
that's a powerful move I expect because
like trade and then the other Rook joins
the action and all of a sudden I was
making fun of this light Square Bishop
but you know Bishop D3 intermediate at
some point will be the case and if you
take E4 then
yeah Nigel short told me that this one
is called for whatever reason I mean
those inner British jokes but did this
kind of uh is called I have no Irish
porn structure I mean you know these
guys that they love each other in the UK
so that's that's called Irish Pawn
structure with all of those isolated a
couple days are also doubled at the same
time so that's that's here you go
uh anyway uh we are getting there yeah
Queen E4 is on the board so now well
Christian Christian
yeah well being inactive sometimes is
not such a bad thing huh
right so Christian is in trouble once
again uh landerman Alex Slenderman
against Chandra akshat uh this one we
I'm not sure if we checked at all
chandrayi being the one lower on the
clocks were always one minute after move
31. yeah I don't think we've actually
taken a look at this so maybe we can
just run this one yeah just quickly it's
like a little bit of a birthday present
e45
yeah yeah uh that's my fault because I
thought it was boring because I've seen
they played the Slavic change but but
not really right E3 and Bishop B5 okay
so at least white is putting in some
effort for this not to be completely
symmetrical and it it already isn't
because the bishop didn't go to F5 and
Left Behind the Pawns
H3 Queen B6 Rook to B1 Rook C8 Bishop H4
well while not that easy to guess those
moves back and forth Bishop between
maybe four Bishop E2 that's been a lot
of moves back and forth really Knight E4
finally we need to trade some stuff and
then then I can yeah this is all right
now the game has begun so now we'll see
what happens but at least yeah here like
the center is defined and then white
clearly sees ah okay that's a key inside
let's uh let's put it in general though
this trade on e4 which is something that
you see I guess quite a lot would you
say that this actually like maybe favors
black in this kind of case yeah most of
the most of the times I mean as long as
you have enough pieces right as long as
you have enough pieces so that white
cannot just go all in on uh Queen side
because he's getting generated like if
we say leave white with the knight in
the queen against the silly bishop and
the Queen and then all of a sudden the
Knight lands on E5 then yes I'm very
happy but yeah that's not the case here
so I'm guessing black if he Maneuvers
well should be more than fine here so
Knight to F7 and I'm not sure where the
knights headed
uh Bishop to C6 well perhaps just covers
covers the E5 square right it was on C6
also covering D5 square but white
threatened to disturb it
so it rerouted to 6 to F7 Bishop to D5
well actually looks extremely solid for
black B6 and then an interesting an
interesting take just to capture on B6
Bishop C4 is something I cannot really
approve on but anyway
uh Bishop against yes he's trying to get
some sort of good night versus that
Bishop but I'm not yeah the bishop only
two he's not the bad right the bishop
182 is not bad and Rook to C5 once again
it's a little bit awkward if you trade
then the Knight has to move then white
captures be B5 uh blackstop upon there
still Queen B4 Rook to E5 yeah that that
that's nice
and uh hang on a second capture only six
and D5 is very tempting it probably
doesn't really work but
D5 at once yeah why not the 501
sculptures and white thinking so he can
trade on E8 yep yet
yeah
but this is this is actually quite
attractive yeah because
right so you have to take with the queen
and then once again it's quite awkward
because white captures on D5 and The
Rook which was perfectly placed on the C
file it has to leave because it has to
keep the night guard it's a B6 or A6
perhaps A6 right to be at least
semi-open file and I'd say Rook C1 and
I'm fairly optimistic about White's
position even though he's a pawn down
because yeah like like still the
background threads here and there uh
still somewhat overextended Pawn
structure like well your ideal setup is
G6 after which you're getting mated
after Queen D4 check right so probably
kind of to avoid the back rank you'll
move the H Pawn but then you're never
safe in terms of the structure right
because even when you play G6 G6 will be
the big link
so I'm very optimistic about white
Physicians here
right let me go back to this one yeah
that that one's quite quite interesting
and we've reached this yeah so he traded
only eight when Bishop D5 and so on
oh okie dokie so let's quickly check
what else do we have our man mikalan
against Dennis cartridge okay these are
these are these guys belong to a group
that's the dream we're all trying to
afford it yeah move forward achieved uh
everything solid black
somehow Warner born in the protest but
but yeah okay and just to remind
everybody there is a rule in place that
you cannot offer a draw until move 40 so
it looks like maybe they've hit it uh
they could now officially yeah but
potentially yeah they wanted to but like
once oh for a draw I'm afraid black
yourself upon and
finally bought five or yeah
with Christopher you this one started
off with something let's check because
we're saving the best here this is one
of the more interesting in terms of
openings
all right yeah you can immediately there
has an hour thank you Christopher is
n't but yeah the other guy's got 15
minutes
Bishop G5 and he just girls Bishop thank
you yeah
who cares about them look at this this
is great stuff
it's all these Joko pianizimos right
look at this this is fantastic
oh yeah yeah yeah what wait a second
what happens
okay never mind Bishop F5 Bishop takes
E4 right F3 I and that that's the moment
we've seen it and it really looked
interesting Bishop D3 so some really
yeah like rigged position right black
has two Bishops
uh he somehow played G5 and the position
doesn't tell where exactly black had the
need to play G5 obviously he had as we
already figured out Queen to D5 Queen to
D5 Knight to D5 uh imagine Rook B8 was
not played so that black would have
would be able to Castle long
I would think that would be very nice
for black anyway Castle short B4 Rook d8
yeah so once we get counter attack
intimate of the internet and it's
another check and you kind of have to go
after it otherwise your piece down right
so King qh oh my God
92
then
yeah Rook C8 Knight D4 captures King to
F2
and equal material all of a sudden I
mean there's been so much happening
there and the materials equal Bishop C4
if anyone I'm guessing black might be
better if the king is safe like might be
better because that somehow he lifted
the Rooks very conveniently and can
double against the a pawn A4 that's what
he does immediately targets Rook B1 B6
so The Rook on A6 can be made fun of but
you know the pawn is the pawn you're
losing the pawn Knight F5 how about that
for a minute Rook takes it's G4 yeah
some fancy stuff King G6 back E4 okay
okay Rook d8
I'm trying to sneak around behind the
corner yeah these guys here checks and
you know ideally I I wouldn't mind that
kind of bringing the other work sure oh
well it's a check Bishop E6 that place
okay the knight's getting Disturbed
right a check over here Knight to H6
rookie two oh
doubling the Rooks here who's who's
checkmating whom G5 is a nice move I
want to say okay Rook takes G2 and the
chat is already see it right
we're looking at you how often do you
checkmate with White's move Knight H6 to
G8 very pretty yeah this would be a
fantastic that's an achievement that
should be you know kind of a chess.com
page or someone else's beige yeah I'm
kind of feeling like he let the chat
chat off the hook with this one they
didn't think there was going to be a
test today but this was a very nice win
yeah of course this these kind of guys
they see it but anyway yeah like Rook G5
and especially you if you're in a type
trouble you're looking like uh okay he
wants E5 but that's not the Checkmate
right let's yeah let's take the pawn
yeah okay
check uh King effect it's been a lot of
checks in this game Rook d8 by the way
it's another Checkmate threat very nice
rugby two finally yeah and
7 F5 Bishop A2 oh wow calm
rookie two so not Rook G as we look
he played Rook G7 not Rook G8 Rook G8
Rook d8 perhaps and you can't really do
much and and the B Pawn is running yeah
yeah so this is how black maybe is
trying to promote uh just all you got to
do is not get checked tomato G7 what's
the point of Rook G7 let's sign up E6 or
something yeah but that would require
you to uh two rookie two so E6 is not
even running anywhere Knight to G4 well
that's a that's one sharp game whoa
and then it's still kind of still going
so I'm looking for what the trick really
is for weight because otherwise black is
just three moves away from it yeah I
mean I'm so tempted to say that this
works because I understand yes like you
block The Bishop's scope and why it
actually can play six but then the bone
certainly costs white already
check and then just uh clever move with
the king is needed is clever enough
yeah yeah
those pawns are not as dangerous
the king is here like everything stops
the pawns and also black still has one
must be just winning here B3 was just
played and just because see if there's
like an actual trick here for white or
not because yeah feeling having a little
trick here it's just going to be a queen
that's appearing on the board for black
um
easy explain anyway okay okay so expect
this one to kind of wrap up here pretty
soon
uh right but I feel I feel somewhat
tricked that yesterday we've started
this one and it was like half games
finished yeah the other ones absolutely
like clarified some calm end game well
you know you can talk for hours about
how lent this month's position was yeah
and resources and now it's in wow that's
so much I'm overwhelmed with all the
Tactical possibilities here and there
yeah every day is a different experience
you never know what you're gonna get
when you tune in
mm-hmm
right so what do we do then
all right what else is uh what else is
happening
uh what else is happening in the a group
or you may want to ask
uh well the guys are actually still not
out of
um out of the birds in terms of time
control all right what move are we on
here the let's move 39 okay really just
play the Arab H3 almost there
but bones are getting traded so well
perhaps in this direction of the eight
Pawn not being able to promote
but this yeah since black did not
collapse immediately this will actually
go for for quite long okay
and the other one just uh just to check
uh over here it actually did simplify to
what I believe is a completely drawn-ish
we could just fast forward to them or
rewind a bit Yeah and fast forward what
has happened after Knight D6 Bishop
takes Rook take was played uh traded
here and Bishop to D7 so he can't really
or for whatever reason he didn't play
Bishop A4 which I thought wasn't a bad
move
he decided to trade go Bishop D7 but
then
white is just on time to win the pawn
back
and Traders trade the Rooks as well yeah
so this is this you can't really win
okay so we expect this one also to end
in a draw
the players they're getting serious dude
this is I guess
is there something different about round
two than like round one because like
round one you know there's like maybe a
little bit of nerves you're not you
don't know what the term at Hall you
don't know where you're sitting maybe
you're not quite sure you know which
side am I putting my water on you don't
even know like the little details is it
like is it just a lot easier day two
like in general in the beginning
a little bit warmed up well I think that
these are like once again two possible
scenarios some people they kind of start
a lot of results you know and we all are
getting hyped up but if the field is
more or less even then then still it
Peters out and let's say in the middle
of a tournament you'll have like a draw
around right like that yeah and it might
be quite the opposite one result a lot
of rules one result a lot of rules but
at some point it explodes and this
tournament has no rest days so this is
just nine straight days of Chess so it's
very possible that if things you know
start going wrong for a player they
might just continue to go wrong or who
knows that's very common I mean you get
tired and not only that but also people
we used to have a joke like that like
okay everyone gets this cross table
printed out and yeah kind of based on
the first couple of rounds they are
putting little crosses in front of the
names okay this guy is clearly out of
shape so that's that's my brain that's
my target market times
yeah and and it goes further than this
because if you're they say if you look
at the cross table and you do not know
whom to mark that means
very true so the uh anyway it looks much
more exciting in the big group yeah yeah
just keep the rest of our attention
there then let's see
um all right so Christopher use game
once again I believe so far the most
entertaining out of the positions that I
left no problem staying here for just
the minutes yeah that's what we've
gotten did White have any little trick
here or is black just making a queen
yeah I don't think white has uh let's
yeah let's try to use yeah machine is of
no help whatsoever yeah like like Rook
B7 is not the strongest move
much stronger is to give a check and to
go Rook B1 and this much stronger leads
to the position where black is a
deviation is -6 yeah
that's a much stronger version yeah
rugby seven is even worse well now it's
easy and this is I mean I guess this is
also another thing that kind of happens
once you know it's a computer sound I
mean it's just easy nothing to talk
about yeah why what would you even say
easy win for black yeah we always we
always knew that didn't see anything
quite turns out obviously there's
nothing now all right and you know what
we had a little chat today at the St
Louis Church Club with with some people
that perhaps Jess is the only sport when
I mean any game you watch pretty much
like wait basketball football I mean
usually me as the fan I'm not happy with
what he's done with the player right I
mean where were your eyes you should
have I don't know kicked the ball in the
other direction and so on but we all
understand that it's kind of if I will
go and try to perform that that won't
work but with chess like I'm sitting
here with my I don't know old 10 years
old phones and still I'm I know for sure
that I can find better moves than
marketing simply because I have an
engine right so that's unique in this
regard
all right so well our task as
commentators I believe very often would
be to
kind of calm the public and to explain
that yeah I mean it's easy for an engine
but when do people play do players
playing sometimes I mean they have a
very
cool brilliant idea which doesn't work
because of one little move that they're
missing right and then and usually when
you play a game on a high level it's a
dialogue with your opponent right right
I've but I know I'm threatening this and
he said yeah but I've seen this and then
therefore yeah I'm playing this
intermediate move that's what they do a
lot right we've seen quite a lot of that
just this tournament yeah
all right so Christian our guy uh well
he survived uh for now all right he
survived for now he made a few moves
here to catch up on uh he made his move
40 he's down to pawns though but I don't
think it's hopeless okay maybe it is
maybe it is yeah I mean the sea point
the worst of it the king is still very
weak right so so the C Pawn is moving
and perhaps it will not promote but it
will kind of Drive attention of one of
the white pieces and then the king is
doomed yes yes really really rough for
Christian yeah indeed this Irish Pawn
structure proved to be not very not very
good and what's interesting black didn't
even capture an F4 he started by taking
a C3 and then giving a check taking on
F4 which might have been even stronger
Queen F3 Rook G1 well he just
I don't know captured all the pawns is
it even fair I hate when they take all
my pawns yeah they should be four Bishop
D5
white ah yeah that's awkward to White
okay white really has to avoid Queen's
traits so he has to make this ugly move
Rook G2 yeah
four okay anything with a one here
perhaps maybe
might have been kind of more precise way
but what black has done is apparently
good enough
D6 Queen C7 D takes and so on
and we actually take uh I guess this one
I mean we're seeing this trending in
Black's favorite can we actually take a
look at the kedrich game in the B
section I believe yeah we have a major
update okay uh well what's going on so
Black's winning here then we said
Christopher U is upper Rook okay yeah
we're expecting Lenderman is the only
unclear position and country has already
won with black is he the guy on two out
of two by the way yes doing it very well
he is doing very well indeed so yeah
that is actually I can confirm his
second win so all right excellent start
for Dennis cadrich C5 trading here
Knight C6 Knight F3 so some really
strange looking uh I want to say London
system but it wasn't right so in fact
started with the moves of trumpovsky
attack which is Bishop G5 but then yeah
you kind of played the London at the
same time with the bishop 104
uh right looked fairly simplistic ah and
that was the one with the extra pool for
black descent game and black I didn't
expect him to win that quickly yeah if
I'm a Rooks Knight and an extra point
see what happened
to G7 first of all how did he manage to
win the pawn ah Queen H6 is an
interesting move because one could think
okay let's trade and double black spawns
but with this structure well here
specifically why it also has like Rooks
a little bit of The Rook on G3 but with
this structure very often like black
puts the Rooks on the b-file C file
and then it's really awkward right you
move the beatboxer b-pawns attacked and
you build the B Pawn the C Pawn will be
attacked later on Knight goes away the a
pawn is pushed constantly so these pawns
with such material with such structure
it's not such a terrible I'd say such a
terrible double Pawn uh Queen A6 but
still perhaps it was better to trade
because Queen B1 clearly gave black the
initiatives and Knight to C4 white
wasn't sure where he stands so he wants
to keep the queen to keep attacking
and that's very common in fact like over
here once again one should ask himself
like yeah I don't want to trade because
I'm attacking the king but am I
attacking the king with a move like
Queen B1 and perhaps the answer is no
and then yeah and then you're probably
streaming of some sort of Enterprise in
the future some sort of sack but we'll
see what happened
tonight goes there
Knight to F5 Queen D6 I mean White's
still solid right where exactly does
this go 100 round or okay Queen to C6
uh Rook A1 why not B3 I suspect
like something is
there's something there that I don't see
anyway
here A5 says was it still possible to
play B3 because that's what I would have
done maybe B3 Queen C3 and then black
having access to C3 square is also
annoying but
by going A5 you're almost guaranteed to
lose this Pawn
it looks like maybe that's yeah that's
exactly what happened yeah all right
takes and E H3 traded king of two that
that's what we said was we were looking
around here move 40 it turns out that
black is like winning pretty quickly
everyone goes in Knight C4
Rook F1 and and another Pawn Falls right
95 Pawn takes rookie
he just resigns so another Pawn Falls
and you can't even activate the Rook
Rook C2 black is not forced to take the
pawn he'll give a check for the check
perhaps and then y'all were there or
give a check and it was king or D2 just
take on G4 attack these but yeah
talk about his victory he's now the
tournament leader he's got two points
out of two so let's go ahead and jump in
and see what he had to say about his
game
all right thanks for coming on the show
uh Fresh Off Your Victory against Grand
Master Armand Danish tell me all about
how you did it well he played the
tropolski which of course I didn't
prepare like it's like who plays that
from postkay and
um I don't know I play the line that uh
I was I prepared a long long time ago
but he played a very like when he played
Knight D2 after
after C5 that's I think already like
should be equal but to be honest I'm not
too sure like in the game what happened
so if white wants to play you should
play Bishop D3 I think instead of Knight
D2 because that kind of uh I think
somehow prevents me to play Knight C6
but okay he played Knight D2 everything
was pretty much forced like 92 Queen D2
Knight C6 Knight F3 c d e d Bishop F5
everything really four C three six
Bishop D3 take take Bishop D6 Bishop the
sixth Queen D6 he Castle short and now
I'm 100 sure that my engine that's what
happens when you just look at the engine
without actually thinking uh did I
castle and now the best should be like
rookie one with Knight E5 idea but he
plays the most logical Knight G5 and now
I don't know I mean he threatens Queen
H7 Checkmate so I have to go I think I
have to go G6 he goes Queen H3 I have to
go H5
and now he plays F4 and now in the game
like I wasn't sure because in the game
it looked like at the beginning for me
it looked like like I don't have that
like that he's just playing on one goal
to be honest but then in the game like
when I when I found this I think it's
good not really sure this rookie Rook
ae8 rookie seven the idea is that now
whenever you try to push some G4 to
attack me later on to to give me
Checkmate I always have or F6 with Queen
F4 take or even just King G7 King G7 and
the idea is if you take gh5 then just
Rook h8 so I always have some defensive
ideas there so you cannot really just go
crazy like that I guess in a in a Blitz
game you could do it but in a real game
it's gonna be really hard so what
happened later on so
um I played this rookie seven rookie 8
plan so he went now back Queen D3 which
is fine I mean he played some King H1
Queen D3 it doesn't really matter and
now here uh when he played rookie 3
I saw that at his plan is Rook G3 but to
be honest uh I saw I saw a very very
important idea that I think gives me
maybe even the edge is this Knight A5
Rook G3 Queen A6 very important move to
because if you take Queen A6 I think
it's really bad for you because after
ba6 I'm gonna attack your queen side
very easily like Rook B8 Rook B7 Knight
C4 Knight D6 if you play B3 then I
attack the C3 Pawn looks very very
annoying because you have really now
nothing on the king said I mean we're
playing a Carlsbad Pawn structure so he
should be trying to attack my king there
um so what happened Queen A6 Queen B1
and now here a very important thing that
works for me is that after I play Knight
C4 that he never basically has Knight F7
Knight F7 I take Rook F7 Queen G6 king
of f8
and now I always kind of run away with
the king so he played Rook Yuan after
Knight C4 because I was threatening
Knight D2 and now after Knight D6
because now if I manage Knight F5 it
should be just black should be slightly
better because I blocked the whole King
cider now I will slowly do the normal uh
plan that you do B5 B4 so what happened
there is just want to say that after 96
Knight F7 again doesn't work because of
Rook F7 Queen G6 King f8 and now a very
nice line is Queen H6 King E7 and now
you can take on E6 with the Rook or the
queen but uh both are really bad because
if you take with the Rook I go King D7
and I'm threatening Queen F1 Checkmate
if you take with the queen then King d8
and now you're you're losing your queen
uh so that's kind of a tactic that works
out for me so now he he realized that he
cannot sacrifice so he went back like
rookie three Knight F5 rookie two and
now I had a really
to be honest I think that it was just
like uh a very simple position for me
because he has also he's also low on
time and I just pushed B5 B4 I think
what he shouldn't have done is that cba4
I think that I'm just way too active for
for that to work so he should probably
just try to defend passively but then
again I understand that you don't want
to defend the whole time yeah so I think
it was a a a good game to be honest well
we love to hear it here thanks for
coming on and uh we wish you a lot going
on in your third round thank you very
much that was Dennis cadrich who now
sits on two out of two points he said he
was a little bit surprised by the
opening because after all who even plays
the trumpovsky and wow it does have some
people do and then he ended up uh he got
attacked immediately and came up with a
lot of good defensive resources and was
ultimately able to turn the tables uh I
also would like to take a quick look I
think we have a decisive result now in
the Christopher you game if we can run
over there yeah so that's we're
expecting a win
um
we've seen it when it was some porn
races right it's a B3 E6 that's
something that we've seen B2 a check a
check Rook D1 B1 not much has happened
okay so F6 is the trick because F6 if
you capture it's actually not so clever
because F7 and the Knight controls it
and the pawn it actually does promote
but yeah but
just goes King D6 E7 Bishop G6 and now
black is absolutely safe
King E6
King F5 and that that's yeah and that
was the end of that was there all right
so that is a very big win for
Christopher you
is there anything else that we still
have going on I believe we have at least
two more games going on in this section
yeah so what I want to say
I want to say that three games were won
with black out of four five out of five
everyone's waiting with black and then
Christian might be in a lot of trouble
with white again and that's what we've
seen right Queen to C7 dc5 the 7c4 queen
E4 uh might as well just [ __ ]
or don't know oh well so what what
Black's debating is does the does he win
after queen of four I believe because it
pretty much forces white to trade
I mean you can give a check on E6 but
then off we go right H4 is hanging the C
Pawn survives yeah hard to imagine how
you survive if the C Pawn just yeah but
also if you trade I mean with Rook being
someone somewhere else at least but not
G2 all rook and pawn endings or draws
right is that true if you're down two or
three buns that's what they said yeah
that's what they said
um okay and then we have Lenderman where
oh a lot of stuff has happened
apparently in the time trouble uh Bishop
D5 was the last moment where he has
looked at it yeah I was very optimistic
for writing this game look to see one
Queen d8 Rook to D1 Queen F6 it's Rook
C1 would be one somehow feels a bit
underwhelming Rook C1 again uh okay so
maybe is there a back rank threat now uh
not really like you're probably hoping
for black to kind of lose control of the
over this Knight with one of the pieces
like Rook A4 with the loud Queen D6 yeah
this is the kind of thing I'm waiting
for
oh yeah but H6 eventually was played so
now King is no longer in danger still I
would believe white has like
a lot of compensation if not more than
that Queen to C5 King H6 King G2
so the problem for black in this
position is that it's very hard to come
up with moves happily
I think you're gonna say is Rook C6 a
move can this be can this be a thing
because you can't actually can't
actually take yeah so you're returning
the pawn this way but at least you're
getting rid of this very annoying Rook
on this seventh ring
so it's this and it might be still very
awkward right because
they they keep telling us screen and
Rook better than Queen and Bishop but it
really depends on the position yes
because this Knight is this Knight is
fairly restricted
yes but maybe a black saves this way I
don't know girls G6 and possibly even
sacrifices the pawn somewhere but it
goes active on the king side
anyway so this game is still in progress
and that's the only one where it's still
I believe that we actually do have one
more interview we have Christopher you
who's going to be able to explain his
win today okay
all right I am here with Grand Master
Christopher you and fresh off his win
against Grandmaster tigron tell me Chris
you how did you do it tell me everything
about it so I didn't have the best
experience against this guy the last few
games because I I had a traumatic and
horrible game where I was much better
and I hung a rook in one move in a in a
much better end game
and I I did not want that to happen
again
so that was my main goal at this game
don't hang a rook like that
in case I get a good position
let's start with the opening so I knew
he played like all different moves on
move one so
I didn't go super deep into preparation
because I I know I couldn't know what to
expect because I saw you when Knight F3
d4c for E4 G3 and it's just like a
random move generator so I just decided
to play the game I didn't go for my
regular opening
um I didn't really want to take him into
what whatever preparation he did so I
went for a little bit of a
interesting sideline
which I think leads to quite complicated
positions because I saw like Gucci Doma
Raju was playing it
and um he's a very good chess player so
I kind of knew that he was doing it and
beating people so it can't be that bad
so Bishop B4 e3h6 Bishop H4 G5 Bishop
g394
and
this is kind of the point I'm
threatening the C3 Knight and I can go
like H5 H4 and get initiative on the on
the king side
and if they don't know what they're
doing is actually very annoying
and I could tell he didn't quite know
what to do because he spent about
15 minutes here
so it was nice to know that I probably
got him out of preparation and I I
didn't never saw this queen B3 move
before most people developed their
Knight with Knight G2
defending the C3 Knight and developing
at the same time but instead he went
very concretely immediately attacking my
Bishop
but kind of the problem is the C5 move
and the Queen on B3 is kind of awkward
because
I feel like why you're just kind of
lacking development here to justify this
attack he needs to first get his piece
to developed before moving the queen now
but I I have no idea what the engine
says so maybe all I'm what I'm saying is
complete [ __ ] but that this is just
my opinion that Queen V3 is not a good
move but maybe it is a good move I don't
really know
Bishop takes ba Rick takes B8 Bishop D3
and yeah here
I felt like I should have a good
position
but it wasn't actually as simple as I
saw it because after Bishop F5 Bishop
takes E4 Bishop takes E4 F3
my my D5 Pawn is surprisingly weak
and despite the fact that none of his
pieces are developed
kind of concretely I'm forced to give up
this D5 Pawn
so he might even be equalizing here
because I was calculating Queen A5
A3
Bishop takes C3 Queen takes C3 Queen
takes C3 V takes C3 Rook C8 92 and I
thought that was I thought that should
be a draw
so I wanted to keep it more complicated
by playing Bishop takes C5 and I and
this was a somewhat risky decision
because he because he literally could
have taken an exchange with after
castles
Knight F6 check King G7 Knight D7
but I I thought I had enough
compensation after Bishop takes E3 when
my super strong Bishops and his weak
King
and I was kind of looking to get this
double-edged position
but instead he played B4
which is the most
safe thing to do because he gets rid of
my C5 Bishop I can't go Bishop D6
because of Rook D1
followed by Knight F6
so after B4 I'm forced to play like Rook
FDA to attack his Knight
and now there's kind of a funny sequence
of moves so Knight F6 check King G7
attacking the Knight Knight H5 check
King G6 and now he forces my king all
the way up to age five and my king on H5
looks very awkward and funny
but in some cases it can be actually
useful because when he plays G4 check I
have King H4 and if I'm not getting
major there the king is actually quite
nice there
92 or BCA Knight D4 kc5 king of two
36. so this was this wasn't this was
interesting because I saw he had like
seven minutes and I had one hour
because I was moving super fast for some
reason
so I didn't really love my position but
I still like my chances to go for the
win here because of his time
so HD1 Bishop C4 so I had a pretty basic
plan of just going Rook A6 for K5 and
attacking his Pawn
and um
I feel like I feel like there was some
way to defend the pawn but it's actually
it's not easy at all to figure out with
only six minutes on your clock
and if again if my king is not getting
mated on H5 it should be a good position
because my Pawn structure is better
so A3 Rook A5 A4 I I'm not really sure
what the point of this these last few
moves were because if you think about it
if he had went um after Bishop C4 if he
went A4 immediately I would have went
like Rook A5 or Rook A6
and instead he plays a free get gets my
Rook to A5 and only now he goes A4 with
my Rook on A5 and I was very confused
like
what this what what this was all about
because I think it was kind of due to
his time pressure he was panicking
and and the thing is he has no mate
he tried to get some mating like Rook D6
but it's not like imaginary because King
G6 and now making is safe again E4 Rick
takes A4 Rook d8
so yeah he's still he's still going for
me at this point he doesn't really have
anything better to do because he's down
the pond
and I have these pass pawns on the green
side
so Rick A2 check King G3 Bishop E6 I
like this bishop E6 move because he was
threatening like Rook h8 Rick takes H6
with possible check mating ideas but
Bishop E6 prevents this because if Rook
h a bishop takes F5
or Rook G8 King F6 Knight takes H6 Rook
E2
now
[ __ ]
rookie two um
H4
so we kind of needed to get rid of my G5
Pawn because
otherwise like Rook A2 and his King is
in this mating that because of my G5
font so it's it's kind of ironic that
his King ended up being the one in the
midi net when he literally just played
for mate the whole time but then somehow
his King ended up being the weaker one
due to other factors
G takes H word King takes H4 rook aa2
and here he goes again like Rook G5
French hitting Maiden one
this guy still really wants to check me
my king but I was like yeah let's keep
let's move my king back
and he simply has no maid and here here
we go Knight GA check King f8 Rook D1
once again he threatens Maiden one
this was this was his whole strategy
this game keep imagining made and
hopefully one time I'll wonder it like I
wonder my Rook a few years ago but I
went for kd2 and once again he he was
getting really frustrated because he's
like I cannot Checkmate this guy no
matter how many times I threaten it Eric
takes D2 Rook tasty to E5 B5 F4 B4
negative six like here he goes again
threatening virtual rookie I made I was
like King E7 and at this point he looked
like he was he was about he was about to
like smash the board because I keep
defending his maid F5
Bishop A2 let's try and just trying to
go B3 B2 Rook G7
[Music]
um
okay so after Rook G7 he had one more
trap so B3 E6
um King takes F6 Rick takes F7 check
King E5 E7
I could I could tell he's a I could tell
he's a sneaky
sneaky dude
but the problem is my move Rook E2
I'm sorry
so after after Rick
E2
he cannot go
E6 because of King takes F6 Rook takes
F7 King E5 and the problem with E7 is I
can just take his rook and my Pawn on B3
doesn't block it
so after rookie 2 I think it's simply
completely losing for him
and he could he I was surprised he
didn't go for Rook G8 again
trying to mate me but the problem is
Rick takes E5
and it's a very unfortunate day yeah I
feel you well it's great to have you on
thank you for coming on and good luck in
the rest of your tournament Chris thank
you
that was Christopher you on his big win
over tigrin hartunian came in with a big
lofty goal the goal of just not hang a
rook and he managed to do that today and
a little bit more with a huge win and a
monstrous interview now I believe uh we
do have a little bit of updates that we
can make on these standings I know that
the UE game this one ended in a draw but
with that we're actually going to begin
wrapping up our coverage for the show
today we will be back every single day
at 4 P.M central time but let's just let
you keep you a little bit updated as to
what has been happening in the a group
uh ilioniznik had a big win today that
puts him at one and a half tied with
nijat absof who had a win uh in round
one we have you Yang Yi coming up with a
draw he has one point he will be going
up against Hans Neiman who also has one
point as our Marquee matchup for
tomorrow uh vidit and Nicholas theodoro
are still playing it out so we don't
know exactly what's going to happen
there but uh this is a very exciting
tournament there's still quite a lot
that could potentially happen now in the
B group here are these standings uh we
saw a lot more wins today ronik sarwani
Dennis Kendricks and Christopher you all
getting a point and we have two people
people with a perfect score so far
sudwani and kadrick sitting there with
two full points Christopher you right
behind them and we still do have quite a
few games uh left to go we got Linderman
we got Cantor we got Carrillo we got
Chandra all waiting to finish uh their
things so with that uh I think it's been
kind of it was a little bit of a slower
day I would say but sometimes that means
The Best Is Yet To Come what are your
thoughts on today Mira well you know
slower that the more games are still in
progress when we uh when we are about to
leave but we've seen it all the queen
Sacrifice from Ninja right like uh
Christopher you I really enjoyed the
interview yes
and really really a lot of results
especially like the big group we expect
that four out of five games will be one
with the black pieces right with only
one potentially being a draw but that's
once again I'm walking Dangerous Ground
because yesterday I've claimed land
Demon's game to be a draw and he wasn't
right
once again yeah you're always up in the
air when it comes to the fall chess
classic and once again if you do want to
reach us on social media use the hashtag
fall chess classic thank you everybody
sitting here watching with us whether
you're on YouTube whether you're on
Twitch it's been an excellent day chat
has been insanely clean it's just one of
the nicest chats nice you have to hope
for so thank you to everybody that's
tuned in we'll be back tomorrow at 4pm
central time please make sure that you
check it out and that today concludes
our coverage of round two of the Fall
chess classic
thank you
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited